لقد قدمت دول الحلف دعما غير مسبوق لكياف
وكلها متفقه على ان ابواب النيتو مفتوحه
لانضمام دول جديده
[موسيقى]
اخبار العلم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
مرحبا بكم على واقع معارك ضاريه في دنيا
احباط ثلاث هجمات اوكرانيه استهدفت مقاطعه
المقبله
يؤكد ان جميع الحلفاء متفقون على ضم
اوكرانيا لحلف شمال الاطلسي وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن يقول ان واشنطن
ستبحث اتخاذ اجراءات ضد اي زعيم سوداني
يريد استمرار العنف والسير بالبلاد في
اتجاه خاطئ في وقت تستمر فيه اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الثقيله في مناطق عده من العاصمه
السودانيه وفي ظل انقطاع واسع للكهرباء في
الخرطوم وعدد من الولايات
توتر المتصاعد بين برشتينا وبلغراد بسبب
الاوضاع في شمال كوسوفو الرئيس الصربي
يقول ان انسحاب رؤساء البلديات الجدد في
شمال كوسوفو هو الخطوه الاهم لوقف التوتر
في حين تدعو رئيسه كوسوفو صربيا الى وقف
دعمها لمن وصفتهم بالاصابات الاجراميه اذا
ارادت سلاما حقيقيا والناتو يقرر نشر قوه
اضافيه
اشبيليه الاسباني يتوج بطلا للدوري
الاوروبي للمره السابعه في تاريخه بعد
فوزه على روما الايطالي بركلات الترجيح
فقد احتكم الفريقان لها بعد التعادل بهدف
لكل منهما في الوقت الاصلي الذي شهد تالقا
لافتا للحارس المغربي ياسين بونو الى
اللقاء